do you still get because i know you used
to be where you're always thinking of
failing you're always thinking of like
[ __ ] i'm going to get fired i'm going to
get this they're going to hate me do you
not do that anymore do you say
specifically yeah do you think you're
more confident now with just your acting
and your ability
or do you get overwhelmed no no no it's
different it's how is it different
and what did you do to make it different
i i've never wanted to talk about this
but um
i guess i will
it's
it's podcasting
so you know before when i would be in
things like
years ago i did a show called animal
practice i didn't have a podcast and and
at the time my stand up i wasn't making
a lot of money on the road so everything
relied on you know let's i have to
become a serious regular it's got to run
for seven years so then i can make you
know my forever money right
but now it's like
acting is
not the forefront of the thing it's like
i um
if i get fired
fine
right you really think that no but also
secondly
no not but that that's there right but
there's a second element to it which is
also
i've done so many
things i came to a realization that i've
done
10 movies i've been a series regular on
three shows but i've done six pilots
right i've done
so many guest stars right i've done on
every
and it's like i understand how it all
works and i also understand that i'm
good
wow
that's an accomplishment like there's i
i i can sincerely say that
there's no one
that can do it the way i do it
right and i know that i can
kill it in a different way than another
actor can
none that it's better or worse i just
know that when like when because i mean
when eli hired me eli was it wasn't
because i mean i auditioned but eli was
like no i saw you on something else
and that sprung up
you know i mean that bobby would be
perfect for this role right
so it's like oh if he saw me in
something else that means that he
thought it was good
right so then you know you kind of think
you know and the first scene was with
kevin hart and i remember it was one of
those scenes where
they had these gigantic green screens
you're in the desert right and there's
like these machines it's a big sci-fi
movie
right there's like
hundreds of extras with guns and you
know what i mean
and so it's like it's so many extras
what's it called the movie's called
borderlands is based on a video game
so i remember walking from the tent to
this thing and i just remember because i
saw rose and ami eunice do this
she said um
i'm the best i'm the best i'm the best
and
when she right before her she delivered
alliance no roosevelt uses a fighter
okay
and i just said to myself
i'm the best i'm the best i'm the best
you're gonna kill it you're gonna kill
it you're gonna kill like this mantra
positive reinforcement oh yeah and when
i walked on set i killed it
like i i like eli's like
we don't even have to do no let's do
another one for fun
just like that yeah yeah so it's like
and it was like i you know i had like 10
lines in this thing i had to walk around
and grab things and you know
i tied up kevin hart you know i mean so
i'm like kind of torturing him i guess
and i'm just kind of like doing this
little tiny
speech
right not huge not gonna win many awards
but it's like
i know i had to do it and i did it so
you think because of the podcast success
and the millions of dollars you're
making no it's not the money it's what
it is is um
when i go on the road
and i see tiger belly fans or like
because i'm in new york shooting
something right now too in life and i'm
i and i i'm i'm on the street in
brooklyn right on my day off
and people coming up to me going
it's a different thing than mad tv it's
like they know me
you know they'll walk up and they go
they'll sit down and we'll talk
and it's just a different is it that you
maybe you feel like you belong is what
you're saying like like you're like no i
feel like i have a family
you mean